[Music]
in kabul the capital of afghanistan life
here is changing rapidly under the new
regime of the taliban now that the
islamic emirate of afghanistan has been
proclaimed and that replaced the afghan
republic that was deposed in the middle
of august already the city is changing
visibly before i rise the
visual transformation is quite striking
the city used to be
covered with graffiti with paintings of
afghan national heroes of women
activists
of historical figures
now a fresh coat of paint is going all
over that
and increasingly the slogans of the
islamic emirate are replacing the
visuals that used to characterize kabul
as you walk around you can see that
merchants are walking between cars
selling big and small flags of islamic
emirate the white flag with the islamic
scripture that has replaced the black
red and green flag of the now deposed
republic of afghanistan
there are protests now every day mostly
led by women that are being dispersed by
the taliban and yet continue the after
day the taliban have proven themselves
to be a highly successful military force
however the fighters don't have much
experience with the peaceful street
protests that we're seeing now they
haven't been trained they don't have
riot equipment and what they do is shoot
in the air sometimes missing and hitting
buildings
the fact that the new government doesn't
include any women says a lot by itself
and so that is the reason why many of
them protesting many of them are down in
the streets saying if this government
stays the way it is if if there is no
transformation that a lot of their
achievements over the last 20 years
at least in the urban areas afghanistan
will be gone forever
while taliban haven't yet spelled out
what rules they will implement many of
the women are preoccupied occupied and
alarmed uh by the fact that they will
probably be able to continue working in
many professions the educational
opportunities will be reduced
the government has has already received
the agreement international criticism
and has not been recognized by anyone
and yet for now it seems to be
in firm control of the city despite
these occasional demonstrations